if only the Nobel Prizes were awarded in
the summer that's when Stockholm is at
its loveliest in the heart of the old
quarter is the nobel museum the prize
founded by Alfred Nobel is the Oscar of
science curator Gustav Cod strand has
plenty of anecdotes about the
celebrities who have been honored work
very hard in your laboratory all your
life and at the end if you're really
lucky you may get the Nobel Prize and of
course sometimes some people get the
price twice and line is polling for
example photographs of the more than 800
laureates revolve in a display on the
ceiling some prize winners have also
signed the chairs in the museum cafe
like brian kobilka and bob Lefkowitz who
shared the chemistry prize in 2012 cause
strands shows us the place where the
decisions over undying fame in the
academic world are made every October
committees at the royal swedish academy
of science select the laureates in
physics and chemistry so this is the
room where the royal academy of science
meet to select the nobel prize winner
every year they have a box on the stage
and the members go up put their boat in
and then go down again we asked to see
the famous telephone with which the
Academy notifies the winners so there it
is it has happened that they've got the
wrong number or once they actually got
the person with the same name as a Nobel
laureate but who wasn't it was a truck
driver and not a physicist and he told
him that you won the Nobel Prize and he
had to decline sadly this is where the
names are made public after the
selection we meet the chairman of the
Nobel Committee for chemistry his team
proposes the laureates but the final
decision is made by the Academy we
always come up with a unanimous decision
does that usually follow a heated debate
to come to unanimous decision that will
always have to be a hot discussion
although lots of experts are involved in
the selection it's Sven leadings
committee that ultimately comes up with
the names quite or responsibility for a
few days it gives a rock star status to
a few scientists and that puts the
spotlight on science as a whole and I
think that is the important role of the
Nobel Prize in December the scientists
receive their prizes in the Swedish
capital the city hall now full of
tourists is the venue of a banquet for
more than a thousand guests and it's
attended by sweden's royal family this
is the time where the Nobel laureates
can really relax and enjoy their evening
and it's usually enough forgettable
night but now it's summer in Stockholm
and the awards still seemed far away but
this autumn the world will look again to
Scandinavia for the announcement of the
2013 Nobel prizes
you